- Welcome to the future.
- It's Drew Barrymore
and we're so excited to
share the secret behind
how we can get so many
of our amazing guests
into the CBS Broadcast
Center in New York City,
where we're filming the show,
even if they're in Los Angeles
and can't travel to New York.
See my friend Dr. Aliza Pressman.
She's the one sitting with me
or is she?
That's right Dr. Aliza is in our LA studio
beaming into New York, like
something out of Star Trek.
It's incredible.
The cameras are controlled
by our New York control room.
So there's not even a camera operator
in the room with the guest.
So when guests are looking
to get away from it all,
they can come join us in New York,
I mean, LA,
but really it's in New York,
even though they're in LA,
but they're kind of in New York.
Oh, well, you know what?
You get it.
(upbeat music)